Marie so you know you come in now do you
meet the director first do big prints
first what's what's the process first
and he said I give him some of my ideas
and he said I want to organize a meeting
with Prince and actually she only way up
there that morning also and I remember
doing some quick sketches for him he was
not even like looking at me was looking
outside a window and I'm there talking
and he's like I seen his back you know
and at some point I said something I
turned around and then he came I
remember doing like the quick sketches
of the glass with the waffles
yeah and a funny thing happened later on
is that you know in film often you tech
so it's not so white so we produce a
shirt and I had them all tech and I
bring them to him and he said oh my god
it's awful it looks dirty I will never
wear it so we had to redo them
completely did you did you immediately
imagine what you wrote the sketch that
you did well you know I knew his music
and I knew you know like I had seen his
music videos from before so I had a
feeling of what I wanted to bring to
make it look more iconic you know and
what was his reaction when you when you
when you did he immediately get it or
did yeah I think you know because he
needs all the videos he wore those
ruffle tux shirt you know but like come
cheap tux shirt
so you came up with like the the cold
version to take from dad but make it
more romantic more you know you know
Marty stick I mean in my view you know
yes and I see people on right away that
I was not trying to change him in any
way I was trying to and on to see who he
was and didn't she achieve that you guys
so how many years did you see people my
color my shape pretty dark skin trying
to dress like Prince with eyeliner yeah
Marie you've got a whole generation of
how many people were rocking lace in
this in this thinner just raise your
hand all you lace wears was with your
mama's sewing machine yes she did a
great job you guys give her a hand
thank you great pick Albert was it was
it just because we did not have much I
did not have much else especially when
we did we shoot in LA and GM would come
in the trailer and would iron shirts for
ya teamwork so when the Purple Reign
tours happened the movies out and you
see a ocean of thousands of people
wearing their version of your wardrobe
how does that feel it's a compliment
yeah it's very exciting yeah I remember
that yeah she's so modest
wait okay where's the inspiration like
European 17th century yeah actually
mention 18th century 17th century the
cravat a little more 19th century I
mentioned some of the superior to him
yeah and he had no problems as you guys
ever but
did you ever have disagreements about
something that you'd actually I'm trying
to get some controversy come on help me
I told him what I felt and some time I
did not agree you know and some time you
would look at me and said French women
always want to you did he just a
musician just a musician question um did
he ever say it's hard for me to play the
guitar with the ruffles just flying no
he didn't have that problem
the genius how do you play the guitar
get it work like you love the lace I
mean he had never worn this before you
know and I think this you know and I the
thing over there I and you know yeah it
was great because he stopped borrowing
our clothes so you know is your you're
right